the movie opens in lrange Ohio where we
are introduced to our protagonist Curtis
lefor he is currently having an
apocalyptic dream where he sees a
rainstorm made of motor oil just then he
wakes up and finds that it's a sunny day
Curtis lives with his wife Samantha and
their deaf daughter Hannah Samantha is a
housewife who spends most of her time
taking care of her daughter the family's
income comes from Curtis who works for a
construction company one day he is
working at a construction site when it
starts to rain causing his job to fall
short as as a result he visits a bar
with his colleagues and enjoys some beer
meanwhile at home Samantha and Hannah
look at the rainstorm outside and learn
how to spell some words in sign language
later Curtis goes to drop his coworker
dewart at home while in the car they
talk about their lives and dewart
believes that Curtis is having a
wonderful life however the latter
reveals that things are not as pretty as
they always seem upon arriving home
Curtis checks on his mute daughter when
his wife suddenly hugs him from behind
she tells him that Hannah is still
unable to connect with other children
children however he asks her not to
worry asserting that everything will be
okay over time the next day as Curtis is
cleaning up some trash a heavy storm
appears in the sky soon after a
lightning bolt strikes the ground which
disturbs his dog red it breaks free from
its chain and charges towards Curtis
biting his right arm at that moment he
wakes up in bed revealing it to be
another bad dream Curtis doesn't like
storms later during breakfast he gets
worried for his daughter who is playing
with red so he takes her away from it
when Samantha tries to intervene he
lashes out at her and leaves without
having his breakfast even at work Curtis
seems to be distracted as he keeps
looking at his right arm while working
at the construction site he sees a swarm
of black birds in the sky he asks his
co-worker about it but the latter
doesn't notice anything that afternoon
Curtis and his wife attend their
daughter's school meeting where they are
briefed about some sign language which
they can use with their children later
that night Curtis experiences another
bad dream this time he and his daughter
get into a car accident due to yeah
heavy rainfall he wakes up from a days
and sees a couple of men outside trying
to break into their car soon after one
of them takes his daughter away while
the other strangles him from behind
Curtis suddenly snaps out of the dream
in a cold sweat gasping for air these
recurring dreams make him very anxious
and depressed which is visible on his
face Samantha also notices this and asks
if he's sick but he assures her that he
is fine following this his wife and
daughter leave the house to attend a
school Fair while he stays home since it
is his day off he proceeds to construct
a fence in their backyard so that he can
secure his dog there once he is done he
looks at the trash pile and wonders how
he can get rid of it just then his
attention is grabbed by a door that
leads to the basement he manages to find
the key and enters it to measure
something as the evening Dawns Samantha
and Hannah return home and they are
perplexed as to why their dog is kept
Outdoors Curtis doesn't give much of an
explan exp ation stating he prefers it
that way afterwards he experiences
another distressing nightmare it's
raining and his daughter is looking
outside through the window when he
approaches her he is startled to see a
stranger standing outside their house
the whole ground then begins to shake
and everything levitates as if the house
is falling at this point he wakes up in
his bed and realizes that he has wetted
the bed it's all that damn dream rain
moments later Samantha walks into the
room to check on him but he stops her
from getting closer probably due to
embarrassment after cleaning up the bed
sheets he visits a local library along
with his daughter where he goes through
some books about mental illness on their
way back they buy a bunch of canned
foods for some reason as night falls
Curtis cleans the basement and stores
the food he brought when he doesn't
return home for a while his wife Peaks
through the window and notices light
coming from the basement overwhelmed by
all of these apocalyptic visions and
increased insomnia Curtis finally goes
to see a doctor one day he discloses
that he's been having trouble sleeping
for 4 days now hearing this the doctor
prescribes him a mild sedative and also
refers him to consult a psychiatrist in
Columbus Curtis then goes to the
pharmacy to buy the prescribed sedative
for his sleeping on the other hand
Samantha visits the insurance agency to
inquire about the funds for their
daughter's operation to restore her
hearing much to her Delight Curtis's
company turns out to be a reliable
insurance provider that will cover the
entire expense for the operation she
then returns home and shares the good
news with her husband this makes Curtis
very happy and it is the first time he
Has Smiled in days the following morning
he wakes up feeling remarkably well
likely due to the sedative he took the
previous night even his wife notes his
improved appearance however his
hallucinations persist he hears
thunderous sounds while working even
though the sky is clear this makes him
very uneasy causing him to rush to the
trash bin and throw up he abruptly
leaves the construction site and decides
to visit his mother whom he hasn't seen
for a while now it turns out that his
his mother Sarah has paranoid
schizophrenia that surfaced in her about
the same age that Curtis is now
concerned that he may also have this
disorder he asks her if she has
disturbing dreams in response she says
that she experiences hallucinations from
unknown people who whisper to her as
days pass by Curtis's mental health
deteriorates more and more as he
struggles to distinguish his
hallucinations from reality one day he
comes up with a plan to build a Calamity
shelter and calculates the money he
needs to purchase the equipment upon
realizing that he can't afford such an
amount of money he visits a bank and
takes out a home improvement loan
without telling his wife he also puts
his construction job in Jeopardy while
secretly taking equipment from the
company to build his shelter when he
confides this plan in deart the ladder
is suspicious about his mental
well-being but he eventually agrees to
help in any way he can as soon as
Samantha and Hannah leave for the school
Fair the next day Curtis summons dewart
with the company Dozer and the two start
the construction work in the backyard in
the midst of the digging process
Curtis's wife returns home who is
shocked and understandably upset by all
of this that night a heated argument
ensues between the couple which further
escalates when Samantha learns about the
home improvement loan that he took
despite being aware of their financial
struggles she demands an explanation for
everything but he leaves saying that
there is nothing to clarify the stressed
Curtis then takes more than the
prescribed dose of the sedative as a
result of this he has a seizure at
midnight which sets Samantha into a
panic she hastily proceeds to call the
emergency services but he blocks her
from doing so after he recovers he
finally talks to his wife disclosing
everything he has been experiencing for
the past few months he claims that it's
not just common dreams but it's feelings
his wife listens to him but she still
can't comprehend what he's saying the
next day Curtis and Samantha take their
child to the hospital in order to
schedule her cckar implant surgery after
going through a brief checkup the doctor
informs them that the surgery JY will be
done in 6 weeks in the ensuing days
Curtis becomes increasingly absent from
work as he is busy setting up the
shelter when he shows up at work one day
his boss calls him to the office and
expresses dissatisfaction with his
recent performance he issues a warning
also ordering him to make up for the
time that was squandered later that
evening Curtis is visited by his younger
brother Kyle who has learned to bet his
recent irrational behavior from his wife
he asks about his well-being to which
Curtis claims that he is fine after a
brief cold conversation between the
brothers Curtis asks him to take red
with him as he no longer wants the dog
that night he has yet another disturbing
dream in which he sees his wife standing
soaked in the kitchen and staring at him
without uttering a word she also has a
knife beside her which freaks him out
the following day Curtis's boss visits
his house and sees the shelter he made
in the backyard he is also aware of
Curtis secretly using the work equipment
for his personal work so he fires him
and gives him only two 2 weeks worth of
medical insurance benefits he further
tells Curtis that he has placed dewart
on 2 weeks unpaid administrative leave
for violating the company's rules when
Curtis reveals this news to his wife she
gets so mad that she slaps him for
losing his job at such a crucial time
several days later seeing that Curtis
still loves and cares for Hannah
Samantha can't stay angry any longer she
goes to talk to him and suggests that
they cancel their planned beach trip to
cover their daughter's surgery she also
asks him to find another job as soon as
possible which he agrees to in the next
scene the family attends a social
function at the Lion's Club so that they
can restore some sense of normaly to
their strained and increasingly isolated
life while enjoying some quality time
together Curtis is confronted by dwart
who blames him for his job suspension in
a burst of Rage he punches him in front
of everyone which ensues in a physical
altercation between the till enraged
Curtis knocks dewart to the floor
overturns a table and and unleashes a
frightening verbal tirade upon everyone
present he prophetically shouts that a
devastating Storm is Coming insisting
that none of them are prepared Samantha
is worried to witness such a condition
in her husband but she somehow manages
to calm him down before taking him back
home that very midnight a sudden
emergency alarm startles the family
prompting them to rush into their newly
built shelter Curtis carefully puts the
antitoxic masks on his family members
and waits for the storm to pass the day
after Samantha wakes up her husband and
asks him to open the door asserting that
the storm has subsided however Curtis is
so obsessed with his theory that he is
now scared of going outside despite this
she somehow manages to encourage him
finally making him open the door as they
make their way out they're welcomed by a
clear blue sky with no sign of a
Calamity they also notice the neighbors
cleaning up broken tree limbs and other
yard debris as power company trucks
restore electricity along the street in
the aftermath of of this event Curtis is
overwhelmed with regret for dragging his
family to the delusions that he's
experiencing fueled by this remorse he
finally agrees to seek help from a
psychiatrist during his first session
the psychiatrist tells him that he needs
to cut ties from the shelter that he
made to avoid further imagination the
doctor also advises the couple to
proceed with their planned annual Beach
vacation once they return Curtis will
need to get psychiatric care in a
facility away from his family the scene
then cuts to Myrtle Beach where Curtis
is seen building sand castles with
Hannah while Samantha is cooking for
them during their Beach time Hannah
signs the word storm pointing out at a
distance as Samantha steps out of their
Beach House a thick oily rain begins to
fall staining her outstretched hand much
to her shock she also Witnesses larger
storm clouds passing over the ocean the
tornado like water spouts reach down to
the ocean's surface and the tide pulls
back as a Nami Looms in the distance at
this point she realizes that her husband
was right this whole time the two
exchanged glances and the movie ends as
they hurriedly rush back to their
shelter subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching